Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man over wankity, is such a wonder thing, behind us all, come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for...
Looks like a great sphere marbled with clouds.
It was nice of the confederation on Omega to give us a vacation on Earth.
Yeah, and especially for Psyche, she needs one.
You're not in good shape yourself. The only guy around here in condition is me.
Coming in now, it's a shame that we stop out in orbit.
Earth already sure know a lot of ways to make you lose time.
Venerable old Mother Earth, she has rules of her own.
And one of them is no craft is allowed to land.
I never knew that Earth had a ring like Saturn and Uranus.
Nonsense, that's their solar energy ring.
Calling Hummingbird, welcome to Earth.
Will you please proceed to landing base Doppler?
You will be given clearance to land in six minutes.
You will be given instructions.
You need to be alarmed.
Your friend Psyche has a good constitution.
All she needs is a few weeks rest and she should be alright, so don't worry.
Oh, here they are.
Confirm your diagnosis, Doctor.
No broken bones or serious lesions.
A sprain here and there.
Clean treatment.
As for you, Lieutenant, a little rest wouldn't do you any harm.
You've had rather a heavy load lately, is that right?
You, you're apparently made of very stern stuff.
Well, I sincerely hope all three of you spend a very enjoyable time on our dear old planet Earth.
Super Space Station, you realize?
You'd think you were really out in the country.
Hector?
Naturally, you have nothing to declare.
No Moonstones, no Cosmic Jewels, no Art Object from Thetis, no Gadget from Japania.
My luggage! Where's my luggage? It's disappeared! I've gotta find it!
It's really panic still here.
Shuttle service departure for Earth leaving on Platform 7 in 4 minutes.
Next shuttle service for Earth leaving.
I think it's that way.
You're the group from the Hummingbird, aren't you?
Mm-hmm.
You'll leave from the fourth platform.
We've been detailed to conduct you.
Gentlemen, please take your seats.
Immediate departure.
It almost feels like we're Grouchley's prisoners.
Only General Grouchley's men never smile.
This is Group Kepler.
On your right, a large pleasure and recreation center, the cemetery in space.
Oh, we gotta go see that. I hear it's terrific.
Hey, what are those?
We need a guide to explain all.
Look at that.
Down there.
A belt of solar mirrors that surrounds the Earth and supplies all its energy.
Here you see the ring of solar mirrors.
We are 36,000 kilometers above the Earth, the so-called geostatic zone,
because an object placed in orbit here moves at the planet's rotation speed
and appears stationary from the ground.
That is why there are so many obstructions here.
Please excuse the delay.
Magnificent clouds like a beautiful dream.
Ladies and gentlemen, please take your seats.
The sound you will hear in a few moments is caused by our re-entry into the Earth's atmosphere.
Lois is the Atlantic Ocean, Italy, France.
We are now circling back.
Ladies and gentlemen, we will be landing any moment now.
The anti-gravitational system will now be put into operation.
Prepare to land. Thank you.
I have the old friends from Omega.
Well, now I can tell you the whole thing was cooked up.
We asked Omega to let you spend a little time with us here on Earth.
After all, you deserve it. Naturally, we wanted it to be a surprise.
Well, dear friend, that it was. Your secret was well kept.
Nobody gave it away, not even at Port Doppler.
Yeah, for a while, we thought we were prisoners.
I'm afraid I'm getting sleepy. I'll get some sleep.
It's a little bit hectic, I know, but tomorrow we'll get out of this city.
You're too famous, you heroes. You saved the earth, you know.
You'll be recognized. You won't get any peace here.
Anyway, seen one city, seen them all.
Tomorrow, it's the country for us.
See young Psyche. You're going to be yourself in no time.
Peaceful it is here, as though it could go on forever.
What on earth are those?
Why, and those are cows, of course. What do they look like?
Well, that's right. You never saw them.
Come on, Omega, no cows. Well, there are lots of holes in your education.
You sure these things aren't dangerous or anything?
No, no, no, no. Isn't she a magnificent specimen? Look at her.
See the ones you call dangerous?
It's true, on Omega, we have nothing like this.
There's nothing like this on any planet we know.
Ah, look, there's the house. Down there. You see it?
My faithful old servant. Well, in a way, I mean, she's considerably younger than me.
Is this another one that's not dangerous?
He doesn't look too ferocious.
He might gulp you down in one bite.
Heroes are not like straight. We have routine here.
Summer at 6 p.m., bed at 8 p.m., same daybreak.
Chickens, that understood?
Does she expect us to lay eggs?
Milk from our hives. You'll like it.
It's like a paradise here. Was it always like that?
We've always heard so much about the violence here on Earth.
It's difficult to believe it's true.
Oh, it's true, all right, and it was probably much more violent than you can imagine.
It's taken centuries for the people of the Earth to resolve their quarrels,
contradictions, become adult, but it would take too long to explain it.
Oh, no, come on, please tell us.
Please, please, tell us.
You'd like to know?
Where shall I start?
Toward the end of the 20th century, things started to go wrong.
Excessive industrialization.
More and more production.
And why all that?
To give people a few superfluous goods, consume products, use them up as fast as possible.
Powering pride of government.
A global view of world mattered less than keeping your clients happy.
As in Roman times, the payoff with the inevitable result that raw materials needed for human development were used up.
For instance, when my old spaceship left Earth in 2023, there were so few metal deposits left, they had to rely on melted-down scrap.
There were junkyards full of old cars, and since there was no more motor fuel, they started using coal.
And then when the coal ran out, it was wood.
And out, there was only one place to look up, and they turned to the sun natural.
And so, as my old crate was leaving Earth, they started constructing what was to become the Ring of Solar Mirrors.
And they were building those gigantic radio telescopes to listen in on outer space,
trying to find other civilizations in the universe.
They had learned that they had to be put up above the ionosphere since long-wave radio frequencies didn't penetrate that layer.
And in time, Omega's allies were discovered and all the rest.
And as for population growth, galloping, especially among the poorest billion human beings the year 2000,
over 30 billion one century later, can you picture it?
An endless line of misery and hopelessness.
Well, there were little local wars to settle things, a show of strength,
with the poor always the victim to work off tensions and frustrations,
for nothing is more reassuring when you're miserable than knowing that someone else is more miserable,
preferably an enemy.
But going all the way, total destruction.
Time to time, they would toy with the idea of a bomb, a couple of megatons, creating millions of victims.
And in the end, they had weapons thousands of times more powerful.
So, no, no, what really brought about the collapse was genetic engineering.
It started innocently enough by grafting genes resistant to malignant cells.
Of course, strictly for human purposes. It always starts like that.
Then it was so parents could choose the baby's sex color of eyes, his or her size, even his intellectual capacity.
At that point, all genetic research became top secret government business.
To produce super athletes or well-endowed young ladies or men in blue or green or orange, all according to enzyme balance.
But as for producing geniuses, they tried to outdo each other.
All the leaders appropriated to themselves the genes that would guarantee their progeny brilliance and long life.
They were creating a dynasty of the elite.
Their descendants would rule forever.
actually such a secretly dealt and the common people rose up in revolt and then in a desperate
attempt to maintain their privileged position the rulers resorted to the oldest trick in the book
scapegoating it was all the fault of the others the enemy and they started pressing buttons
war of 2183 eyes of course i was in suspended animation somewhere out in space oh it was
terrible wasn't a pretty sight our earth what was left of it around the year 2200 they were
back in the middle ages but the strong triumphed over the weak then slowly another renaissance
dawned on the earth you recall the first had been in greek times pericles socrates when man himself
was the measure of all things and the second came two thousand years later the italian quattrocento
of da vinci pranuti and that other one what was he called michael angelo in the 25th century a
thousand years later the third renaissance emerged man was no longer an instrument to be manipulated
His right to happiness was inviolable.
War was outlawed.
And the mad expenditures it had occasioned also.
Natural resources were strictly controlled and a world government was at last proclaimed.
It was well remembered that technology is the handmaiden of war.
The first tentative communications were made with other constellations.
And they went out and discovered the existence of Omega.
Rules were set down.
Other planets were not to be pillaged.
It was a new era.
Our space trains would go out and bring back, from uninhabited worlds only, certain metals and water.
Really, water?
Yes, that's right, water.
A substance we are sadly in need of on Earth.
And ever since all's gone well?
No, alas, it hasn't been quite so simple.
Poor old Earth has been subjected to her troubles, yes.
One was the spread of computers and the whole domain of data processing, which took on an alarming proportion.
Hello, 7312. Your output last week was below normal by 17%.
But I couldn't keep up my work. I was sick last week.
Until your performance improves, all your goods and services will be reduced accordingly.
Food, clothing, leisure activities, minus 17%. Only logical.
Red 2 announced that the marriage rate has attained the critical stage of 7.8%.
We project a return to normal in 7 months, 14 days.
Kindly submit your request then. Thank you.
Name it, and it's 100 to what a computer was in charge of it until the people revolted.
also had her problems with the people who wanted to control her weather.
Climate.
Well, for some time, weather had been controlled very nicely by satellites,
which could provide sunshine or clouds, rain, hail, whatever you wanted, wherever it was needed.
And sure enough, one day, a group in the North wanted to teach the South a lesson for whatever reason,
and they deprived them of sunshine and rain, and other such little practical jokes.
But the Earth is a small planet, and its ecological system is all one.
Terrible catastrophes that resulted the satellite toys were taken away from these sorcerers' apprentices.
And we learned our lesson.
There was no longer place for such child's play.
Humanity would behave as an adult or perish.
Alas, I'm afraid there will always be madmen with their delusions of grandeur.
Madmen, yes.
But they must not be entrusted with power.
Meanwhile, look around.
We've come back to the simple things, as in the 19th century.
If only men were wise enough to learn wisdom.
Ah, yes, my young friends, I'll show you everything you want to see, and more.
What's that up there?
The ring. I'll pay a visit later on.
First, take a look over there.
Those great balloons.
That is our water reservoir.
Comes from other planets.
We fill giant high-resistant plastic containers.
And naturally, transporting the balloons that large isn't very difficult when you're out in space,
because they're weightless.
And they're ice, of course.
And when we need water, we just draw one down toward the Earth a few thousand meters altitude.
It melts, and we take all the water we need.
Rather nice system, don't you think?
It's brilliant.
When we just saw them, we couldn't figure out what they were.
Yeah, over there.
Now, we're at, let's see, 35,860 kilometers from Earth.
You know what that means?
Yes, we know all about that.
This is the geostatic altitude.
An object is motionless to an observer on the Earth.
That's right, and that's why all this junk is floating around.
The old radio telescopes, and they still work.
No, they don't make many discoveries these days.
As you know, a surface of 500 billion wavelengths squared
enables receptions of signals at a distance of 100,000 billion kilometers,
which I agree is only 10,000 light years, which is a drop in the ocean,
and we should consider, as well, the narrow width of the beam,
which, in the calculation...
Sorry, only, what's that over there?
What, that? Oh, that's quite a story.
Ever since the 21st century, rich people have wanted to be buried out in space,
nearer to heaven.
Well, that's what they wanted.
Why not? Only as things went on, it got too crowded.
So it was decided to stack all the deer departed in this floating cemetery.
Space centers for rest and leisure activities, mainly for space station personnel.
What's the big disk on top?
Ah, that's the captor for solar energy.
Everything comes from the sun, you know.
It has life, all energy, petroleum oil and wood, all the sun.
Do you know how much energy it sends us continuously?
It's a colossal figure, 250 trillion horsepower.
That's how much.
And what did we do with it?
I'll tell you what we did with it.
We took sunbaths, that's what.
Hey, there, what's that?
Is that what I think it is?
Ah, I think you know what that is.
That is the graveyard of Rex and Hawks.
If you wanted to see it, there it is.
As early as the year 2000, there were 400 objects in the sky,
and I'd hate to tell you how many were there later.
As usual, it took a tragedy for anything to be done about it.
A man needs some catastrophe to make decisions.
You could say he sees his future with hindsight.
What was I saying about all this junk?
Oh, that's right.
Well, a lot of junk.
One day, a ship was returning to Earth on automatic guidance,
And in those days, the crew still had to go into suspended animation.
Well, it collided with one of these wrecks that somehow got in the way.
The shock was devastating.
So it was decided to clean up space.
Put all these objects here in one place.
Gentlemen, we are now passing over the remnants of the spaceship Invincible,
the heroic craft that defended us in the Great War.
Favorite site for tourists.
They come here on pilgrimage.
It's a museum.
There's leisure center there.
Then you have the amusement park, full of all sorts of extraordinary games,
fast food pills shows.
Well, do we go on?
Mm-hmm.
To the ring of solar mirrors.
Say again, my young friends,
the sun isn't only the source and reserve of all energy on Earth.
It is the very source of life itself.
Everything you see here functions because of the sun.
Are we on course?
There's the ring.
That's right, to the ring of the mirrors.
G-ring.
There, the sun.
Have you ever considered what the results would be
if the sun's rays striking the Earth
were not just scattered about,
focused in a single point?
All right, it's top secret, only I think you ought to know if the Earth is ever menaced again.
As it was when you saved us, we now have a way of warding off any aggressor, only it's not quite enough.
Once it's perfected, nothing will be able to resist it.
The hardest metals will melt like butter and glow white hot.
And whole planets will melt, be destroyed, reduced to spatial dust.
Such a weapon will defend the Earth from orbiting stations.
The Earth will be invulnerable.
And you're not afraid of creating such a powerful weapon?
But I told you its use is entirely defensive.
You don't think for one minute.
That's what they always say at first.
Of course, there's a danger.
Anyway, our tests haven't been successful yet.
Something always goes wrong.
Some say they think it's sabotage.
Who can say who would do it?
That Cassiopean bunch, who else?
Consider their position if you had had your sun gun ready when their rocket was on the way.
Are there any Cassiopeans here?
A few working as space technicians, only they're all trusted above suspicion.
and it can't be any of them.
Can you be so sure?
We've had a lot of experience, I can tell you,
and I wouldn't trust any Cassiopean.
As everywhere, there are good and bad, but Grouch is mad.
What's that group of people up there?
Something's happened.
You're right. Let's have a look.
Looks like he's dead.
Police, go on about your business.
There's nothing to see here.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir.
I didn't recognize you with the suit.
As you see, one of our officers was killed.
Looks like he was thrown from his vehicle, sir.
Was he alone?
Yes, on routine patrol in this section.
Have you found his vehicle?
Yes, Lieutenant. It's orbiting around. Should come back in ten minutes.
It's programmed, then.
Quick, there's no time to lose.
You'd better stay in the shuttle.
Yeah, it's okay.
We'll each take different directions.
He can't be very far.
Closer than you think.
You see what curiosity got you?
Didn't anyone ever teach you it's not polite to poke your nose in other people's business?
Education isn't what it was in my day. You need a lesson.
Yeah, okay, you win. Only first, I'd like to know just what's your game.
Well, I guess I can tell you, since the two of you are gonna die,
That cop surprised me as I was finishing a little job of sabotage, routine stuff.
He tried to get me to go into his vehicle.
Oh, he had a little scuffle and he lost his helmet.
Guess he was hot.
Anyway, the poor fellow didn't pull through.
I rode his police vehicle once around and got off here.
Now, does that clear it up?
Bye, you guys.
Hey, wait a minute.
Aren't you those jerks from Omega?
The big heroes?
Yeah, sure.
Now the boss is gonna be happy.
Okay, you guys, your hours come.
Now you know what happens to heroes.
Watch out behind you!
That's the oldest one in a book.
I haven't fallen for that since I was a kid.
Such a wonder.
Come take your place.